liebe zuschauer die dokumentation inside
es zehn tage im islamischen staat und
jetzt im rahmen einer phoenix runde
insider es die diskussion herzlich
willkommen bei uns und bei uns im studio
ist der autor des films jürgen
todenhöfer
dezember 2014 waren sie zehn tage mit
ihrem sohn als kameramann im islamischen
staat unterwegs werden es gerade gesehen
da der anstieg ist bei uns islamismus
expertin sie leiten in berlin die
beratungsstelle hjs türkisch und heißt
leben
beim zentrum für demokratische kultur
und sport kümmern sie sich um menschen
besser gesagt um deren angehörige die
sich dem radikalen islamismus zugewandt
hat im dschihadismus möglicherweise
jetzt auch in syrien oder im irak
unterwegs sind michael das ist bei uns
profilierter nahost-experten seite 2015
präsident der deutsch arabischen
gesellschaft und entropie dennison
amerikanische politikwissenschaftler und
gründer von transatlantic networks man
muss es glaube ich noch einmal betonen
es ist ich habe es gerade gesagt in
ihrem film ist dass wir das auch erwähnt
die aufnahmen die filmaufnahmen die wir
gerade gesehen haben stammen aus dem
dezember 2014 also vor anderthalb jahren
die frage ob ein solcher besuch heute
noch möglich werden nachdem sich ja sehr
viel verändert hat der islamische staat
hat gewaltig an boden verloren im
wahrsten sinn des wortes ich glaub 30
bis 40 prozent seines herrschaftsbereich
steht militärisch möglicherweise mit dem
rücken zur wand
insofern ist das ein historisches ein
einmaliges dokument das wir abgeliefert
haben
ja ich glaube später wäre der versuch
auch möglich gewesen und ich glaube der
islamische staat ist nach leider noch
lange nicht geschlagen
die haben die städte tikrit ramadi
falludscha verloren aber sie denen sich
in libyen aus sie dehnen sich in der
ganzen welt aus es kann sein dass sie
ihren staat verlieren
die hatten einrichten staat also da
keinen guten start aber einen richtigen
start mit mit der ligna in dem film
aussteuer namen unter allen es kann sein
dass wenn sie wacker und mausolf erleben
dass wir gerade gesehen haben
dass sie dann den staat verlieren aber
sie haben sich darauf längst eingestellt
gehen in den untergrund und werden dann
die größte terroristische
untergrundbewegung sein die die
geschichte jemals gesehen hat wir
sollten sie nicht unterschätzen
also die gefahr ist keineswegs gebannt
jetzt sehen wir noch mal auf den film
production was bringt uns der film
wissen wir jetzt mehr als vorher über
den islamischen staaten es gibt ja aus
diesem staat außerdem propagandafilmen
sonst keine bilder
na ja es gab 2014 die doch sehr
deutliche weiß dokumentation dieses
britischen journalisten dann diese
bilder inzwischen wissen wir sehr viel
über den islamischen staat war die haben
rückkehrer wir haben aussteiger wir
haben inzwischen interne dokumente das
heißt 2014 war das wissen noch relativ
gering
inzwischen ist es relativ groß das heißt
wir wissen schon ziemlich genau wie es
dort die strukturen sind wie doch diese
bürokratie ist letztendlich hier wir
kennen jetzt natürlich sehr viel von den
jugendlichen was sie dahin zieht dass es
für mich dass relevante warum gehen die
jugendlichen dahin was sind das für
jugendliche welche chancen gibt es sie
zurückzubekommen
und da muss ich sagen hat sich etwas
verändert 2014 haben wir jugendliche
loch zurück bekommen da war die grenze
auch noch durchlässiger das ist
inzwischen fast unmöglich das heißt im
konnten mit dem konflikt wieder türkei
auch etwas zeit aber das heißt auch der
was für mich wichtig ist der islamische
staat ist ein absolut paranoider start
und er lebt von seinem image und das
image ist das wichtigste und deswegen
habe ich so ein bisschen bauchschmerzen
wenn wir immer so da wenn sie hat
todenhöfer immer das so hinstellen die
schlimmste terroristische sie ist
terroristisch sie ist gefährlich man
darf sie nicht unterschätzen aber es
gibt auch andere bewegung al kaida ist
aus meiner sicht viel gefährlicher weil
sie hoch intellektuell ist was da es
nicht ist und es lebt von diesem image
wir sind die die die api besten am
meisten ärgern da der westen hat am
meisten vor uns alles versauen wollen
die jugendlichen dämonisieren
wir dürfen sich verharmlosen das will
ich jetzt auch nicht aber wir müssen
auch aufpassen dass wir nicht an diesem
image mit stricken
in der gegend studiert in syrien sie
kennen sie sehr gut wie wirken
möglicherweise auch schon mal model
gewesen vor dem dsds zeit wie würden
diese bild auf 7
das sind zunächst einmal beeindruckende
bestandsaufnahmen dessen was da
geschehen ist wie der islamische
staatssicherheit ausbreiten können und
das alles ist natürlich sehr
unglückseliger es hätte alles so nicht
sein müssen
jetzt hat der islamische staat in der
tat an gelände verloren aber ich teile
ihre auffassung dass man nicht glauben
sollte er stünde mit dem rücken zur wand
denn er hat das eingepreist in der tat
er wird nicht zu besiegen sein so ohne
weiteres
man kann grundsätzlich nicht
terroristische bewegungen mit
militärischen mitteln besiegen mit
luftangriffen besiegen bei diesen
luftangriffen sterben jedes mal
unschuldige und das ist dann wieder
neues rekrutierungs instrument vergessen
wir nicht ist eine ganze staaten
zerfallen in der region als ergebnis
unfähiger arabischer regime als ergebnis
unfähiger als ergebnis von unzähligen
militärischen intervention des westens
und das ergebnis ist dass wir millionen
von menschen haben ohne perspektive und
solange die situation so bleiben wird
und das wird noch auf jahre und
jahrzehnte der fall sein haben
organisationen wie diese immer zulauf
auch wenn vielleicht islamische staat in
dieser form wie wir ihn jetzt erleben in
2 35 jahren nicht mehr existieren mag
aber dann kommt eine neue organisation
die möglicherweise noch brutaler ist
denn wenn staaten zerfallen dann beginnt
die stunde der milizen
denn ist ein welche informationen haben
sie den film entnommen
es war spannend diese bilder zu sehen
es war natürlich auch beeindruckende
ihren mut zu sehen da hinzugehen mit
ihrem sohn habe ich habe auch ein
bisschen meinen moralischen bedenken
darüber
es kam mir ein bisschen vor als ob einer
amerikanischen kamerateam eine
drehgenehmigung bekommen hat in den
warschauer ghetto 1945 reinzugehen jetzt
die welt ist gott sei dank viel
friedlicher heute die zahl der toten ist
viel geringer
aber diese verwechslung von täter und
opfer indem man reingeht und man hört
dort wie gut es ist unter eine strenge
ordnung
man sieht verletzte soldaten nicht
deutsche soldaten sondern isaf soldaten
man hört eine rechtfertigung der
sklaverei mit bezug auf amerikanische
indianer und sklaven
man sieht die ihre folgen von anglo
amerikanische luft ankommen terror aber
man sieht keine massengräber und das war
für mich das problem sie haben
angedeutet mit den orange gekleidet die
in den wasser gehen aber ein massengrab
auf machen und zeigen was da los war
die opfer ich weiß sie könnten das nicht
machen natürlich ist er der frage im
kopf welche kompromisse mussten sie mit
der wahrheit machen um aus diesen horror
mit ihren kopf raus zu kommen natürlich
behaupten sie nicht aber jeder der ein
bisschen überlegt muss im hinterkopf
haben welche wahrheiten haben wir nicht
gesehen und eine die ich nicht gesehen
haben ist einfach die brutalität es war
gemütlich da das einzige was ich
wirklich gestört hat war die kinder der
aus den angel aus den bombardierten haus
geflüchtet haben also der
angloamerikanische bombenterror eine
verwechslung von täter und opfer
ja wenn sie das gemütlich fanden dann
haben wir vielleicht den falschen einen
anderen film gesehen
es war keine sekunde gemütlich ich
konnte natürlich keine gräber selber
aufmachen das ist ja das haben sie ja
auch von peter bergen nicht verlangt der
mit osama bin laden gesprochen hat da
wenden sie jetzt ganz merkwürdige
standards an
ich bin irgendwo dass auch müde wenn man
über ein halbes jahr lang sein leben
riskiert um diese ich wenn sie mal
verbrecherbande zu entlarven und zu
demaskieren
und ich habe zum beispiel auch
interviews manchmal ganz bewusst laufen
lassen wenn ich sie demaskieren finde
wenn einer
einer sagt und ob das 100 millionen sind
oder 200 millionen oder 5 das ist eine
selbst hinrichtung des 1 und ich finde
dass es wichtig ist dass zu sehen und es
gibt ja das letzte drittel ist ja ein
gespräch mit einem amerikanischen
islamwissenschaftler der denise was noch
übrig geblieben ist nach dem film in der
luft auseinander nimmt wer nach diesem
film ich kapiert dass der es eine
verbrecherorganisation ist und dass er
antiislamische weil der islam verbietet
die tötung von zivilisten der islam
verbietet die zerstörung von kirchen
synagogen und moscheen der islam
verbietet angriffskriege all das
verbietet der islam und all das macht
der es ununterbrochen
also wenn jemand nach diesem film und
nach dem buch es gibt ja auch noch ein
buch und ich habe ja versucht mit diesem
buch in dem film ich reich zu werden
sondern ich habe mein gesamtes honorar
für kinder in gaza und für kinder in
syrien ausgegeben auch das honorar
dieses filmes auf der sonne dieses
filmes geht für prothesen von kindern in
syrien die ihre beine und arme verloren
haben 50 haben wir schon versorgt
ich hoffe es werden weitere 50 das heißt
es gibt ein ganzes anliegen dahinter und
wer wäre das nicht versteht da sage ich
interessante ansicht wie sie hier
vertreten obama ihr präsident hat gesagt
ich habe das gerade noch mal nachgelesen
ich wenn sie wollen zeigen dass das denn
ausführliche zitate obama hat gesagt es
ist der nachfolger von al qaida im irak
und al qaida im irak ist die folge
unserer intervention im irak und obama
fährt fort wir sollten in zukunft
erstmal zielen bevor wir schießen noch
eine sorge um den thema vielleicht von
einer anderen seite noch näher zu kommen
das weil ich ursprünglich als film
geplant ist sollte er eine sogar das
videotagebuch sein
als quelle als bewegte quelle wenn man
so will viel bewegte quelle
was waren
tiefe für ihre weise dorthin warum sind
sie dahin gesagt wenn ich ausholen darf
kissinger hat mal über korea vielleicht
nicht ganz so weit zu beginn aber dass
sie wenn sie wie ich unterbreche brauche
ich noch ein bisschen mehr zeit lassen
sie es uns
kurz und bündig zu sagen kissingers den
ich sehr gut kenne hat mal gesagt korea
ist nicht korea vietnam ist ein
erbärmlicher kommunistischer karstadt
das heißt er hat sie völlig unterschätzt
und die amerikaner haben einen hohen
preis und die vor allem die vietnamesen
einen hohen preis dafür gezahlt dass
kissinger vietnam ich kannte und dadurch
einen verhängnisvollen krieg geführt hat
bush kannte weder den irak noch
afghanistan
und ich glaube an dieser aussage eines
chinesischen philosophen wenn man seinen
gegner vernichten will sollte man ihn
kennt und ich wollte mit dem buch und
mit dem film mithelfen dass die menschen
verstehen hallo warum laufen diese
verrückten leute dahin was sind das für
leute und ich finde ihre arbeit
bewundert wird es ganz wichtig dass wir
hier mit den menschen sprechen die
verführt worden sind ich wollte all das
zeigen und ich habe dafür glaube ich
einige risiken in kauf genommen und ich
finde es einfach wichtiger ich glaube
nicht dass unsere politiker zu viel über
die länder wissen die sie bombardieren
sondern sie wissen zu wenig sie hatten
keine ahnung als in afghanistan
angegriffen haben sie hatten keine
ahnung vom irak als die irak angegriffen
haben sie hatten keine ahnung von libyen
als sie gaddafi wegräumen wollten und
das ergebnis ist jedes mal eine
katastrophe jetzt haben nicht ein
gaddafi sollen sich an den argumenten
nicht genug ahnung haben ja um
letztendlich im krieg gegen ein anderer
staat zu ziehen alle diese dinge die ich
genannt habe man ja überflüssig
ich finde also ich hab schon angedeutet
zweideutig wer es täte und wer ist opfer
das ist verschlimmert wenn sie
vereinfachen und dieses phänomen auf
amerikanische kriege reduzieren dass es
als ob wir ausländer und einwanderer für
unsere probleme schuld machen oder islam
die amerikaner sind so wenig
diesen problemen schuld als die europäer
ich glaube die sind vielleicht nicht mit
adam und eva an
aber herr todenhöfer sie müssen ehrlich
sein nach den ersten weltkrieg nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg der gründung von
israel
das war nicht amerikas schuld amerika
hat 1945 ein scherbenhaufen geerbt 500
jahre haben die europäer ausgebeutet
ausgeraubt und ermordet und seit 45
trotz fehler in korea und trotz fehler
in vietnam ist der welt viel besser
geworden
und wenn wir jetzt sagen das eis ist von
americana verursachen obama wörtlich ja
obama würde nie so eine vereinfachen da
einfach sie haben
brechen wir wollen die ursache ist
natürlich auch eine wichtige sache warum
gibt es in einer soll wir sind im moment
noch bei der wirkung der des filmes ich
würde das gerne noch einmal aufnehmen
ist es richtig irgend rothenhöfer
argumentierte mit aufklärung er sagt ist
es wichtig zu wissen wie man da vor sich
hat um auch zu wissen wie man solche
terror-organisation bekämpft ist es
wichtig eine solche filmische plattform
dem es zu widmen
das denke ich schon also die frage ist
immer wie man es macht mich haben so
einige stellen gestört weil man die
demaskierung denke ich hätte man noch
geschickter machen können an manchen
stellen demaskiert sich selber also
christian ämter demaskiert sich selbst
einmal als bisher agieren
ich fand es also noch mal sehr
interessant dass er noch nicht mal die
vorgestanzten ideologischen phrasen zu
ende
rezipieren konnte weil er sie gar nicht
verinnerlicht hat und das ist für mich
wichtig sie sind nicht tief in ihm drin
und da gibt es unterschiede
ich sage immer das sehr platt die deppen
gehen zum es und die etwas
intellektuelle rinnen zu al kaida beide
sind gefährlich ist sehr platt gesagt
ich weiß ja deswegen sage ich es ist
eine platte vereinfachung sage ich auch
aber das gros ist wirklich warum wehren
sie davon angezogen und eben nicht vom
islam und ich glaube das ist daran
krankt der film
sie wollen darstellen zurecht und das
finde ich auch möglich dass der erste
platzierung des islam ist und das ist da
gibt es gar keine frage
und versuche aber jetzt mit einem
anderen islam dagegenzuhalten
der punkt ist aber die jugendlichen
gehen nicht da hin weil sie ja nach dem
islam auf der suche sind sondern wir
müssen an die ursachen warum gehen die
jugendlichen zum 1 1000 kunde eine rolle
spielen mal was wert sein
diese jeweils perspektive einmal
glücklich sei nämlich einmal jemand sein
einmal wichtig ja wichtig sein
ersatzfamilie bedeutung gibt sehr viele
orientieren und diese radikale ideologie
die sich auch noch religiös begründet
gibt ihnen diese antworten erfüllt
dieses das ließ lassen die sich nicht
wegnehmen
ein islam deren herzlichkeit der der
mainstream islam ist er gut ist erfüllt
diese bedürfnisse bei diesen
jugendlichen nicht deswegen arbeiten wir
mit den eltern um an diese bedürfnisse
ranzukommen und diese bedürfnisse müssen
alternativ gefüllt werden danach fragen
demgegenüber stehen einfach so tragisch
und so grausam wäre diese art abenteuer
spielt es gibt ein ist ganz
unterschiedlich gehen auch welche hin
die einfach mal einem großen projekt
beteiligt sein wollen sie schreiben
geschichte sehr sehr angesprochen mit
den mythen mit denen gearbeitet wird mit
dem überlieferung das sind keine die man
hinterfragen kann das sind religiösen
überlieferungen hinterfragt wenn der
prophet das offenbart hat und prophezeit
hat das wenn die armeen in scharm stehen
dass dann der große endkampf ist das
kalifat ist wieder da
ich bin jetzt die erste generation die
frauen sind die mütter der ersten
generation da bin ich teil eines riesen
projektes für jugendliche die sonst nur
nena sie uns mal eine person
herausgreifen christian ende der da als
pressesprecher des auftritt ein
ehemaliger eishockeyspieler aus solingen
der sich dort geriert mit seinen
allmachtsfantasien als menschen
schlechter kann man das kann man das gar
nicht sagen auch wenn 500 millionen
umgebracht werden müssen damit sich der
islam durchsetzt dann werden eben 500
millionen
die kehle durchgeschnitten was ist das
was ist das für ein eindruck der damit
erwecke wie hat das auf sie gewirkt
diese
die art wie er sich da vor der kamera
posiert hat naja wenn man so will ist
ein psycho pathologischer größen bahn
wahrscheinlich hat ihn in seiner
biografie ich kann es nicht beurteilen
ich bin kein kein therapeut
möglicherweise hatte er in seiner
familie nicht die zuwendung erfahren die
er gebraucht hätte um einen normalen weg
zu gehen einen bürgerlichen leben
nachzugehen normale biografie leben zu
wollen
wir haben es ja sehr anschaulich
beschrieben das ist ja wirklich der kern
des ganzen das eben unterschiedliche
biografische motive dazu führen dass
leute in diese richtung gehen sehr viel
identitätssuche die suche noch bedeutung
das alles spielt eine wesentliche rolle
und es ist daher auch ein fehler wenn
wir immer nur gucken ja ist dass die
moschee die leute radikalisiert oder es
ist das internet das ist wenn überhaupt
die 2 die dritte die vierte stufe der
ursprüngliche sagen wir mal die
ursprüngliche orientierung hin zum
islamischen staat oder hin zu dieser
radikalen ideologie die erfolgt früher
und das sind meistens eben ja
individuelle oder seelisch oder wie auch
immer wir es nennen wollen störungen das
ist eine wichtige botschaft die man in
der tat deutlich rüberbringen sollten
diese menschen für uns verloren
versuchen sie jetzt zu vorsichtig wir
haben einige die psychische störung
haben das kommt vor
aber ich wäre vorsichtig das zu
psychologisieren es sind teilweise auch
sehr gesunde also das wirklich so zu
sagen ich auf dieser ebene
wir dürfen eines nicht vergessen das
fehlt mir bei ihnen im film leider auch
warum ist das so überzeugt dass schiiten
getötet werden müssen das hat er es doch
nicht erfunden
wir müssen uns mit salafismus mit der
der salafistischen theologie und der
daraus entstandenen späteren
pianistischen theologie
auseinandersetzen wir können sie nicht
aus dem islam heraus dass sie ganz kurz
und arbeiten für die zuschauer auch das
ist eine sunnitische organisation der es
unter schiiten sind sozusagen die
konkurrenten innerhalb des anderen
konfession eine andere konzeption und
dass ich die hauptseite für die
sanierten ist schlimmer noch als
christen und juden und in deutschland
wird ja gesagt
da wird auch gesagt wissen und juden
dürften bei uns sogar wenn sie diese
steuer zahlen leben aber schiiten
gallium ja und das ist in der sala vier
angelegt wir haben dass die saphire
basiert auf dem wahabismus dem heutigen
saudischen staat islam
das ist eine kleine theologische
strömung das ist nicht der mehrheits
islam das problem ist natürlich dass der
wahabismus über saudi arabien über die
gelder und so weiter in der welt
exportiert worden ist und diese
jugendlichen haben wirklich das gefühl
dass sie die einzigen waren vertreter
des islam sind und diese ablehnung die
musiker die sufis noch sämtliche
schweine werden zerstört jetzt die
angriff auf die moschee des propheten in
medina alles legitim und das ist
angelegt im in der sala vier sozusagen
theoretisch jeder salafist wird militant
gottes willen nicht oder oder äußert
sich quasi ab aggressiv gegen schiiten
oder so fies aber da ist es an gegnern
deswegen brauchen wir neben all den
anderen debatten in politischen auch
eine theologische debatten brauchen sie
auch und insofern mami das zu einfach
was der herschieben klein beginnt mit
ente wie ihr hat der aus sie gewürgt ihr
mit ihm jahre viel zu tun gehabt er war
ihr begleiter sie haben ihn auf der
milan kannst aber die hat glaube ich
wirklich etwas ungewöhnlich da einen
deutschen indie einer solchen funktion
anzutreffen ich habe ein halbes jahr
meine sonntag damit verbracht das ich
mit ihm die skype habe
wenn also andere menschen willen
gegangen sind habe ich die vorhänge zu
gemacht und habe es keine gespräche mit
ende geführt und für mich ist er abu
qatada hat sich diesen namen gegeben
also respektiere ich das und ich habe
ihn gefragt wie er das rechtfertigt das
unschuldige menschen getötet werden weil
der islam barmherzigkeit ist etwas wozu
menschen nicht wissen sie wissen das und
wir haben immer wieder diskutiert ich
habe seine mutter
inzwischen glaube ich dreimal besucht
vorher zweimal
er hat eine großartige mutter die die
natürlich ihren sohn verloren hat
und aber die familienverhältnisse sind
nicht ganz einfacher da eben nur eine
mutter und er war in seiner kindheit ein
gerechtigkeitsfanatiker und da kommt
irgendwann ein gehirnwäsche der sagt
ihnen hast du das unrecht gesehen in
afghanistan und irak aus zugesehen wie
unsere kinder und unsere brüder und
schwestern getötet werden und findest du
nicht auch das dagegen wiederschein
angebracht ist und das findet er und da
sage ich sogar bis zu diesem punkt kann
ich ihn verstehen ich bin nicht seiner
meinung aber ich kann ihn verstehen und
dann sagt dieser gehirnwäsche ihm und du
sitzt hier dieser gehirn werde ist in
österreich ein ein bekannter
österreicher inzwischen tot ist und er
sagt ihm also du sitzt hier also auf
nach syrien auf in den irak auf lasst
uns kämpfen und dann kommt das seltsame
der gehirnwäsche was sie wahrscheinlich
am besten verstehen
dann kommt ein punkt wenn die mal
gehirngewaschen sind denken die nicht
mehr nach und dann glaubt er keine
unschuldige tür aber eine änderung der
sklaverei die lange fort bevor der
österreicher nach solingen kam war es
schon lange auf der spur er war ja schon
in großbritannien in haft weil er mit al
qaida magazin da an geworden ist mit dem
robert baum zusammen und man seiner
kinder als gern haid waren nicht ganz
einfach der gehirnwäsche der dann aus
ist der österreich weiß wenn sie meinen
der mache ja mohammed mahmud der hat ja
hier in berlin mit mit unserem deso dogg
zusammen die seminare bremen gegründet
das ist die militante kameradschaft
das entscheidende ist das entscheidende
an die familie ist dass das eine das
dass das erste mal die materialisierung
also die formgebung einer radikalen
jugendkultur meisten das ist das was ich
immer so copti adis muss
und das ist das was wir jetzt haben zu
der zeit als er anfing sich zu
radikalisieren nur noch nach
großbritannien hatten wir so die anfänge
das heißt wir haben längst nicht mehr
die prediger selbst nicht die radikal
salafistischen prediger sondern es sind
junge leute wie dieser österreicher
mohammed mahmud wie unsere expertise wok
wm
die neuen popstars sind und das ist eben
das erfolg auch vom essen
er hat sich diese popkultur als
vermittlung der ideologie zu eigen
gemacht das heißt mittel mit diesem
zweck mittel zum zweck
das heißt mittels dieser popstars
mittels der elemente der popkultur
gucken sich die videos an kurz
geschnittenem filius werden von solingen
ja das sind die soulige aber dieses
gehalt warfen jugendliche akteure die
wissen wie die zielgruppe denkt wie sie
tickt weil sie selber teil dieser
zielgruppe waren weil sie diese gleichen
gefühle hatten das heißt sie sprechen
sie an wie große brüder kleine brüder
ansprechen und nicht wie ein prediger
irgendwelche fern die jugendlichen
deswegen sind wir haben heute diese
ideologie als radikale jugend subkultur
auf jedem handy ein intel gramm in
diesen apps und wenn eltern heute fehler
machen in der erziehung von kindern was
sie immer gemacht hat über die
jahrhunderte hinweg am älter immer
fehler gemacht dann ist heute die
alternativ lösung die diesen
jugendlichen dann mal zuhört als
attraktive zu den eltern im kinder zu
machen und deswegen ist heute sozusagen
fehler von erziehung von eltern brüche
verlust erfahrungen alles was
jugendliche so durch macht in der
entwicklung hoch gefährlich weil die
alternative sofort da ist darf ich noch
mal zum film zurück kommen zur
entstehung des filmes todenhöfer
wie viel haben sie da riskiert haben sie
eine menge riskiert dahin zu gehen um
diesen film zu machen ja wie gefährlich
war das eigentlich sie müssen die frage
stellen eigentlich finde ich die frage
natürlich
ich habe keinen an einem abend wenn wir
schlafen gegangen sind gewusst ob wir am
nächsten tag noch leben würden ich habe
mein rat ist doch die freude der kleinen
national ich habe natürlich
sie mussten die frage stellen ich habe
rein rational mir ausgerechnet dass die
mir zeigen wollten dass sie einen staat
haben und dass sie nachdem sie eine
öffentliche garantie gegeben hatten als
start dieser garantie einhalten könnten
mein sohn sie am leben zu lassen
ja mein sohn war der festen überzeugung
das ist ein trick gelegentlich rein und
sie werden nicht hinrichten und war
vorher klar wie viel gereist sind
wirklich mutig war mein sohn weil der
nicht an die zusage dass alles geglaubt
hat ich habe rational geglaubt dass sie
die zusage einhalten konnten aber es gab
situationen wir unser fahrer war ihr
jihadi john mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit der henker den sie
alle kennen der folie umgebracht in der
folie und viele andere umgebracht hat
und der auch zu uns unglaublich und ich
war wir hatten am ersten tag die
schwersten auseinandersetzungen ich
wusste auch am ersten tag ich muss die
auseinandersetzung auf nämlich das ist
forechecking wenn wir jetzt nicht ganz
hart widersprechen und genauso laut
brüllen wie der dann haben wir verloren
war es ein himmelfahrtskommando von
anfang an als sie losgezogen sind hier
in deutschland
es war die schwierigste phase meines
lebens ich glaube ich ihnen gern
bekannteste reise meines lebens und ich
habe meinen sohn tagelang gebeten nicht
mehr zu kommen immer und immer wieder
auch auf wunsch meiner familie und mein
sohn hat mir gesagt ich hab dir
technisch geholfen die kontakte
herzustellen
ich hab dir bei den skype gesprächen
geholfen und wenn du umgebracht wirst du
kannst mich nicht ein ganzes leben des
30 jahre damals gewiss ein ganzes leben
mit dem gefühl leben lassen dass ich an
deinen tod schuld bis denn du musst mich
jetzt auch mit nem haben sie sich die
frage gestellt warum sie die wieder
haben laufen lassen wieder ausreisen
lassen
ja weil sie eben diese zusage die zusage
wurde auf twitter öffentlich gemacht mit
einem tollen bild wo das haben wir einen
film gesehen wo dann das kalifat
zusichert dass ich zurückkehren würde
und dass wir nichts geschehen würde ich
glaube dass sie sich das nicht leisten
konnten aber es gab situationen vor
allem als ich diesen ghd von den henker
einmal unmaskiert im nebenzimmer eines
restaurants da kam es zum ausbruch die
haben gesagt sie versuchen uns
auszuspionieren
sie haben sich dann alle abends
getroffen haben nicht mehr mit uns
gesprochen haben auch nicht mehr im
selben raum haus geschlafen wie wir da
dachten wir dass sie nachdenken ob sie
diese zusage einhalten
aber ich meine diese zusage was war denn
sie
ich kann mich an eine szene im film
erinnern ganze land sagt und wenn ihnen
etwas zustößt dann wird der der ihnen
was antut bestraft werden und ich glaube
da auch irgendwie die mundwinkel
verzogen also das war eine interessante
angelegenheit da für ihn also es gibt
nichts negatives was ich über den
islamischen staat nicht sagen würde ich
halte die für eine ich halte für viel
gefährlicher als kalkreuter bei keiner
ist meistens platz nehmen aber wir
dürfen ja auch eine
meinungsverschiedenheit haben neben aber
ich glaube eins muss ich auch sagen sie
haben zwei zusagen eingehalten sich
lebend raus gelassen und sie haben mir
mehr möglichkeiten für interviews und
für filme gegeben als alle terrorismus
eingesetzt haben filmmaterial wieder
ausweisen
sie haben ja auch viel material also
etwa 1 1 gesagt gelöscht gestrichelt zum
beispiel eine sache nachdem der
islamische staat behauptet es gebe keine
bettler im islamischen staats und mein
sohn hat mit bettlaken fotografiert also
war das bild abends wurde von jihadi
john gelöscht das durfte keine bettler
gehen oder sie haben uns bei dem
interview das ich mit mit ende mit abu
qatada und einem anderen geführt habe
ein kämpfer der mosel gekämpft hat da
wollte friedrich ein bild zusammen mit
mir haben als erinnerung jetzt gar keine
bilder er hat immer gefehlt
und als wir das bild dann im auto
gesehen haben sahen wir dass die ihre
maschinenpistolen und an den kopf
gehalten haben hinten
das war auch kein sympathisches bild für
den ice also wurde des abends gelöscht
also es sind auch sachen gelöscht worden
ich würde sagen ein zehntel aber wir
hatten relativ für mich erstaunlich viel
freiraum viel mehr als ich bei den
taliban hatte viel mehr als bei der esa
mit einem mythos verbunden haben hat er
den erwartet dass sie möglicherweise
auch seine botschaften mit
transportieren ungewollt also ich glaube
wenn sie in irgendein land gehen wenn
ich jetzt in die usa gehe und ich habe
ja in ihren
in ihrem land ihre führenden politiker
auch kennenlernen dürfen weinberger und
wie sie alle heißen ihrem
verteidigungsminister
die haben alle eine botschaft die wollen
alle was rüber bringen
wenn ich nach kuba eingeladen werde oder
in syrien bin und mit dem präsidenten
sprechen will mir irgendwas verkaufen
natürlich wollten etwas verkaufen die
wollten verkaufen wir sind ein staat und
wir haben arabische politiker arabische
diplomaten vorgeworfen dass meine
abrechnung in dem offenen brief an den
kalifen der ist ja in der ganzen
arabischen welt veröffentlicht worden
viel zu hart gewesen sei weil ich alle
kontakte mit ihnen abgebrochen habe ich
habe gesagt ihr seid keine muslime ihr
seid antiislamisch ihr seid kriminelle
und ich hab das in einer deutlichkeit
lage macht mit der sie möglicherweise
nicht gerechnet hatten aber ich fand
dass wenn ein mann wie abu qatada sagt
wir werden alle töten
die nicht zum cas zum islam sich
bekennen oder zum christentum oder zum
judentum und wenn das hunderte von
millionen
ich fand dass es da keine gesprächsbasis
mehr gab
also habe ich radikal auch in meinem
buch ein strich gezogen und habe gesagt
da gibt es keine komponist hatte darf
ich fragen
zudem hat der wie wenn sie jetzt den
film sehen der von ihrem todenhöfer hat
der der er ist nahm hat das dem den
islamischen staat genutzt oder geschadet
kann er daraus auch nektar saugen aus
dieser darstellung
ich meine dass es den lager genutzt hat
obwohl sie den nachher natürlich auch
verteufelt haben weil es zeigt einen
funktionierenden staat und wie bin laden
war gesagt hat die leute folgen den
starken esel nicht den schwachen und
solange diese staat sich behauptet
militärisch und politisch hat es
anziehungskraft für die ganze welt in
unserer globalisierten zeit
wir wissen wie man mit totalitären
ideologien umgehen und wir wissen auch
wenn die ein terrorherrschaft auch noch
ausüben können über territorien ist es
viel schlimmer als wenn sie so ein zu
kämpfen sind aber im globalisierten zeit
alte selbst
es ist bald kein territorium als solches
mehr besitzt nicht mehr aus eingängen
chicago vielleicht werden die global auf
rache sein und wir müssen darauf
bewaffnet aber zu sagen wir sollen die
nicht vernichten weil dann gibt's
zerstreute terroristen in der welt sagen
also nicht sie aber es gibt leute die
sagen wir provozieren nur deren ärger
peitschen ein zuckerbrot ja ich bin der
meinung wir müssen immer beides machen
und dass die strategie die jetzt
aufgelegt ist wo die irakis auch viel
mehr machen als die amerikaner am anfang
gemacht haben
in ein staatengruppe ich denke schon
irak ist heute besser als unter saddam
hussein ein
und das glaubt aber kein einziger irak
aus die im gespräch mit uns aber und
seen haben die kurden und zum schutz
genutzt
aber das war nicht nachhaltig
unterdessen haben die schiiten mit
unseren lesern auch den schutz genutzt
es war nicht nachhaltig jetzt vielleicht
sind sie der meinung er töten hilfe nach
nine eleven trotz attentat von von
soldaten anders nach nine eleven hätten
die amerikaner sagen sollen grenzen zu
taliban
das ist deren problem ausschließen
lassen in 20 jahren steht man roboterarm
er ein grenzen zu
wir müssen keine sorgen mehr haben über
oder wir sollen uns nicht mehr darum
kümmert den persischen golf für die
japaner die chinesen die europäer sicher
zu halten
wir kommen nach hause isolationismus pur
das haben wir nicht gemacht und ich
finde es ist besser
natürlich haben wir nicht alles richtig
gemacht normandie war auch keine geniale
die normandie jetzt verlangen die mit
dem irak zu vergleichen welche welche
die das engagement des westens in im
nahen osten das ging ja schon in den
1980 er jahren los in afghanistan da man
hier auch damals gewesen da haben wir ja
die mutter ihn ausgestattet gegen die
sowjetarmee und die gewaschen dann
später auch gegen den westen gerichtet
haben dieser bekommen habe was ist da
falsch gelaufen was wäre zum beispiel
gewesen wenn 2003 nicht im irak
interveniert wäre wäre das dann besser
gelaufen das war hier eine
denn 2003 saddam hussein nicht gestürzt
worden wäre auch wenn er blutiger
diktator war der allerdings erst ein
diktator geworden ist so viel erfolg
nachdem er von den usa sehr stark
unterstützt wurde vor allem im krieg
gegen den iran in 1980 er jahren wenn
sie diesen sturz von saddam hussein 2003
nicht gegeben hätte dann würde es heute
einen islamischen staat nicht geben
weder im irak noch in syrien noch in
libyen hat es auch nur ansatzweise
islamistische gruppierung von bedeutung
gegeben
nach den interventionen und dem versuch
des regimes in syrien ist alles
zusammengebrochen wir haben jetzt weite
flächen die sozusagen ohne herrschaft
sind ohne kontrolle und das wirklich
erstaunliche ist wenn man sich dieses
ganze vergegenwärtigt man kann ja in
realität lesen und kann verfolgen was
geschehen ist in den letzten jahren die
politisch und militärisch
verantwortlichen weder in den usa noch
in europa noch in der nato lernen aus
ihren fehlern sondern sie bereiten die
nächsten militärischen interventionen
vor insbesondere in libyen es werte
nächste fokus werden aber da hitler wenn
du jetzt wenn die der westen es nicht
getan hätte hätten wir gaddafi und das
saddam hussein nach wie vor dort fest im
sattel sitzen ja die westlichen staaten
haben doch diese diktatur mit ihnen
jahrelang die besten geschäfte gemacht
die amerikaner haben die leute die sie
gerne durch gefoltert sehen wollten
liebend gerne sogar dafür hat dazu
ersatz geschickt auf das dauerte also
man hat engstens mit diesen leuten
zusammengearbeitet
ist es doch ein ein unglaublicher unfug
zu sagen also die die offizielle
darstellung ist häufig die dass die
amerikaner das westliche staaten
intervenieren und humanitären erwägungen
weil baschar al assad die menschenrechte
nicht achtet in seinem land bei der fast
bomben auf seine bevölkerung wird das
alles ist richtig das tut er auch seine
furchtbare finger aber das soll nicht
der grund für militärische intervention
es geht um geopolitik es geht um
machtpolitik es geht um allianzen es
geht darum russland china kleinzuhalten
fernzuhalten
es geht darum den iran klein zu halten
eine normalisierung mit dem iran nach
möglichkeit nicht zu machen ist ein
ziemlich schmutziges geschäft und wenn
man sich damit näher befasst dann wird
einem wirklich schwindelig
es haben wir auch sozusagen mit und ich
als europäer möchte weder das eine noch
das sagen na gut man kann sich sagen wir
mal sachlich und nüchtern über gegebene
politische zusammen
austauschen man kann alles versuchen zu
verstehen was dort passiert oder man
kann mit ideologisch motivierter
emotionalität vermeiden überhaupt nur
nachzudenken
und ich bin der meinung man sollte diese
dinge ganz nüchtern betrachten die welt
ist nicht mehr so dass wir eine
hegemonialmacht haben die usa die nach
ihrem eigenen gusto wie 1989 lange zeit
die welt gewissermaßen nach ihren
vorstellungen ordnen kann
es gibt andere akteure in der
internationalen politik die mehr und
mehr auftreten auch wenn uns deren
verhalten vielfach nicht gefällt
namentlich russland und china aber auch
nichtstaatliche organisationen die sehr
mächtig und einflussreich sind google
amazon und andere über milliarden gelder
verfügen es gibt also eine zunehmende
multipolarität in den internationalen
beziehungen und was wir lernen müssen in
der westlichen politik nach meiner
tiefen überzeugung ist die welt nicht
mehr nur zusehen aus einer imperialen
perspektive der ganze kuchen soll uns
gehören sondern wir müssen lernen auch
mit anderen zu teilen und zu sagen okay
wir müssen uns miteinander austauschen
wenn das nicht geschieht dann haben wir
militärische konfrontation auf dauer im
nahen osten und zu nennen und zu nimmt
auch mit russland das erklärte jetzt
eigentlich auch nicht die aber die
attraktivität des ersten sie auch
angestellten erklärt in einer form eine
schwierigkeit weil ich muss es geht ja
darum alternativen zu bieten wenn der s
attraktives oder dschihadistische
gruppen allgemein wenn ich mit den
eltern arbeiten geht es ja darum an die
bedürfnisse der jugendlichen ran zu
gehen und diese bedürfnisse werden
gerade durch die radikalen gedeckt also
wie kann ich sie alternativ decken und
da habe ich natürlich bei dieser politik
schwierigkeiten die demokratie positiv
als als positive alternative
darzustellen
ich will es gar nicht so in diese große
globale nur zwei beispiele guter freund
von mir sagt das immer sehr prononciert
salafismus ist für uns im moment in
politisch das größte problem
saudi arabien ist außenpolitisch einer
unserer wichtigsten partner ägypten das
was wir jetzt und assisi haben ist alles
andere als demokratie und das heißt
jetzt habe ich einen jugendlichen der
zusagen demokratisch aufgewachsen ist
der aus was für gründen auch immer in
einer totalitären ideologie sein heil
gefunden hat
und ich will versuchen letztendlich ihm
doch die demokratie das freiheitliche
leben jedoch schmackhaft zu machen dass
es etwas bringt
das von ihm auch keine gefahr für andere
ausgeht da kann ich ihm natürlich geht
die welt nicht schön reden ja das nicht
möglich da noch ganz kurz ergänzen darf
es kommt ja noch ein aspekt hin zu wenig
sehr wichtig finde es ist doch wenn man
es mal ein bisschen kommentiert
formulieren will geradezu absurd dass
ausgerechnet salafistische bewegungen so
ziemlich die einzigen sind die normalen
muslimen auch jugendlichen muslim in
deutschland oder anderswo in europa
signalisieren hält es ist okay dass du
muslim ist und dass du deutscher bist es
ist gut sei stolz darauf hast sozusagen
beide welten in mir
der mainstream unserer gesellschaft der
begegnet den muslimen in diesem land
oder dem islam nicht mit neugierde mit
respekt und mit einer sehr kritischen
differenzierenden betrachtungsweise sind
es ist ja eher so ein gefühl von bahr
will nichts mit zu tun haben alles ganz
schlimm dass im umgang mit diesen
jugendlichen betreut 800 deutsche glaube
ich im laufe der jahre in den dort das
ist die bekannte zahl 820 wissen wie es
gibt eine dunkelziffer das wissen wir
nicht aber google diese 800 sind aber
jugendliche auch nicht muslime die sich
radikal jugendlichen da eine ganze reihe
von mädchen auch minderjährigen mädchen
sind ihnen die eigentlich begegnet in
mussum sollte in einem mit einer
berlinerin über die grenze gegangen von
der türkei in den islamischen staat ist
inzwischen wieder hier und ich glaube
dass der us den menschen nicht nur eine
ideologie vorgaukelt sondern auch
massive lügen erzählt erfolg zu ihrer
frage ganz kurz kommt da drauf sie
sollten den leuten ihren jungen leuten
die wahrheit sagen sie sollten sagen
dass unsere demokratie auch gravierende
fehler macht und wenn wir
völkerrechtswidrige kriege führen wie
tony blair und george bush dann sollen
sie das sagen die die jungen leute suche
nach der wahrheit die wollen menschen
die ihnen die wahrheit sagen und zu
ihrer frage was die ihnen erzählen
die erzählen zum beispiel der es hier
ihr kommt dort ihr bekommt wunderbare
wohnung willen und ihr bekommt richtig
viel kohle und er bekommt mädchen die
realität
ist sie wohnen in den schäbigsten
wohnungen die sich vorstellen konnten
das heißt da gibt's kaltwasser sieht aus
als die fans möchten auch das muss ja
nicht sein zweiter teil ist deswegen so
werden es wird gelogen
die viele kohle der abu qatada den sie
gesehen haben für den 50 dollar im monat
und als ich ihn gefragt habe
entschuldigen ist sehr sehr sehr
persönlich und ich teile das alles auch
nicht was ich jetzt was er gesagt hat
ich habe gefragt warum sind sie nicht
verheiratet
er sagt ich kann mir das nicht leisten
aber es wird ihnen vorgelogen und da
habe ich gesagt aber ich lese überall es
gibt klar wenn er sagt er eine sklavin
kosten 1500 ich verdiene 50 im monat das
heißt diese jungen leute werden nach
strich und faden auch hier von den
propagandisten angelogen sie gehen in
eine grauenvolle welt sie kriegen eine
große geschichte aber eine studie hat
mir fehlt mir in ihrem film aber sie
haben kommentieren dazwischen
das ist das was mir fehlt und mir fehlt
auch diese ist es etwas eindimensional
wir haben einfach in den ganzen film
kommt nicht einmal vor dass die
zivilisten zerbombt werden massiv von
assad und den russen verbannt werden
die russen haben das krankenhaus in
rabat verband es kommen dem ganzen für
nur als ob nur die amerikaner diese
eindimensionalität ist das gefährlich
wir dürfen die wahrheit nicht
verschweigen wir können ja müssen
aber da kommt aber die liegt ist komplex
aber verdanke ich teile ja in fast allem
ihre auf aber eindimensional wird in den
deutschen medien ganz anders berichtet
wie hier wird nur berichtet wie die
russen bombardieren dass die franzosen
beim angriff auf radikale wir müssen
endlich komplett sei berichten mit 30
unschuldige zivilisten getötet haben das
in falludscha tausende von uns zusammen
gebaut worden in ramadi das ramadi zu 90
prozent zerstört würde all das lesen sie
in deutschen dass wir können natürlich
diese ausstellung auch trotz etwas mich
noch interessieren würde sie sind ja
auch mit dem tode bedroht worden dort
verbal man findet sie überall egal wo
sie sich in europa dann verstecken das
war ja auch kein sehr freundlicher akt
wie empfinden sie diesen umgang des mit
ihnen mit ihrer person
was haben die sie bedroht erpresst in
irgendeiner weise versucht dort auch auf
ihre arbeit einfluss zu nehmen nein wir
hatten nach der reise noch kontakt zu
ihnen
ich habe versucht einen englischen
journalisten frei zu kriegen cameron hat
es abgelehnt
zwei beamte zu mir geschickt und die
zwei hohen beamten haben hier
signalisiert wenn ich aus dieser
befreiungsaktion des britischen
journalisten nicht rausgingen würde ich
schwierigkeiten mit dem englischen
gesetz bekommt und wir hatten weitere
kontakte abu qatada schrieb könntet ihr
bitte den kurden nicht modernere waffen
liefern wir kriegen die von den quoten
anschließen und schickt nicht immer eure
alten maschinengewehre dahin
und dann kam das buch insider ist und ab
da haben sie den kontakt völlig
abgebrochen ich krieg keine antworten
mehr auf meine fragen es gibt keinen
kontakt mehr und dass es morddrohungen
gibt dich die ich zu dutzenden über
facebook bekommen habe interessiert mich
nicht ich werde meinen lebenswandel
nicht immer es unterwerfen
aber was mich freut es und das müsste
eigentlich auf sie freuen fordernd ich
klicke auf facebook ich schreibe sehr
viel auf facebook über diese themen
mehrfach briefe von jungen leuten die
gesagt haben wir haben durch ihre
lektüre verstanden dass unser glaube wir
sollten uns dem eis anschließend falsch
lüders und aniston ihre absicht war ja
dass zu entlassen ist das gelungen durch
den film ja ich meine schon es ist ein
wichtiger film um zu verstehen wie die
situation vor ort sich darstellt aber
darüber hinaus gibt es natürlich auch
noch andere ebenen die erklären warum
die islamische staat nicht so ohne
weiteres zu besiegen ist vor allem
internationale verflechtung
unterstützung besteht ein zeichen der
gleichen zeigt erfolgreiche start ohne
große menschen not ich finde das ist ein
falsches bild dazu angedeutet dass am
ende waren die angloamerikanische kriege
vor allem verantwortlich
dieses thema ist ein weites feld der
nahostkonflikt spielen der phoenix runde
immer wieder eine rolle dass wir auch in
zukunft weiter tun
ich bedanke mich dass sie daran die
zuschauer das war die phoenix runde
im anschluss an die dokumentation inside
es zehn tage im islamischen staates von
jürgen todenhöfer
danke dass sie hier waren und von ihrem
sohn frederik vielen dank dass jemand
die zuschauer bleiben sie bei phoenix